bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté de
réagir en direct sur arte france
d'abord peut-être un commentaire sur les
chiffres que je viens de donner un côté
la pandémie est là
le confinement et la réponse donc il n'y
a pas véritablement à se poser de
questions il faut continuer le
confinement
jusqu'à ce que l'épidémie la propagation
du virus soit deux par elle-même arrêtez
donc c'est une question de bon sens de
responsabilité et sur ce point il ne
peut pas y avoir de critiques à longueur
de temps il nous faut nous confiner il
nous faut être responsable et ça dépend
bien sûr du sens collectif que nous
avons mais aussi de la responsabilité
individuelle
quand vous dites qu'il faut pas être
dans la critique ce soir emmanuel mâcon
va s'exprimer pour la quatrième fois en
six mois il devrait être annoncée donc
en une prolongation de ce confinement
qu'est ce que vous attendez ce soir de
cette nouvelle sortie du président de la
république côté ce que j'attends du
président de la république et le chef de
l'état sait qu'il soit économe de ses
mots
nous avons eu des interventions du
président de la république coutrot
londres une sorte de verbiage parce que
c'est sa nature il doit être solennel et
pour être solennel il doit être bref il
doit marteler ses mots et il n'a pas à
faire je dirais des incidents de
multiples alors bien sûr l'autre jour
lorsqu'il a installé le l'hôpital de
militaires dans l'est
il ya une sorte de verbiage pendant 25
minutes
non il doit être solennel les meilleures
interventions sont celles qui sont
contre bien senties et terminer le
président de la république il est
attendu sur plusieurs points on sait
qu'il va peut-être a certainement
annoncer cette prolongation du
confinement mais il est attendu aussi
sur
les traitements à venir notamment
l'usagé oui ou non de la chloroquine et
aussi sur les conséquences économiques
de cette pandémie en france alors sur
les conséquences économiques moi je suis
de ceux qui pensent que grâce à un
changement de logiciel économique
c'est-à-dire des règles de maastricht et
notamment du financement de l'économie
directement par les banques centrales
aux états on peut repartir très
rapidement et avec aussi la volonté de
nourrir la consommation non pas en
véritablement relevant les impôts ça
c'est une faute
il faut véritablement que la
consommation repart quand même temps que
les investissements et donc de ce côté
là je suis assez je dirais optimiste
c'est jouable mais il faut changer de
logiciel économique et sortir des
carcans idéologiques de bruxelles je
pense que c'est en bonne voie en ce qui
concerne les questions du confinement et
en ce qui concerne je dirais la date à
laquelle le confinement le déconfinement
vais arrêter pour pas en parler
aujourd'hui la faute d'edouard philippe
a été débloqué dans la commission
denquête haut à l'assemblée nationale et
il est tombé dans le piège lorsqu'on lui
a posé la question des continents
il ne s'agit pas aujourd'hui de des
confiné il faut poursuivre le
confinement et sans doute jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
s'agit pas de mettre une date mais il
faut insister sur cette nécessité
on voit que ça paye on voit que le dic
le confinement est véritablement la
solution donc il ne s'agit pas de
tergiverser le président de la
république doit être extrêmement ferme à
ce côté et ne pas faire je dirais un
discours trop long mais il doit faire un
discours martelé et ferme
ça pose aussi le problème la
problématique du télétravail qui va se
poursuivre la scolarité aussi un des
enfants à domicile
bien évidemment là il est clair que pour
les enfants c'était très difficile
et là je sais que il faut de temps en
temps avoir des soupapes
parce que les enfants peuvent pas rester
je dirais confinés comme dans une
véritable prison et là lorsqu'ils
sortent ils doivent sortir véritablement
avec une attestation dérogatoire il doit
tourné en famille sans faire du jogging
et bien évidemment il faut qu'ils aient
la possibilité de voir qu'on va en
sortir
aujourd'hui il y a les vacances il y a
bien sûr le télé la télé école qui
fonctionne assez bien l jeu j'ai de bons
échos à ce type mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que c'est lourd et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut être
véritablement discipliné et ne pas jouer
les surhommes
je vais tenir très rapidement sur la
question des masques et de l'uzège oui
ou non de la chloroquine là encore
qu'attendez-vous du président de l'arjel
tropiques je suis bien incapable de vous
répondre je ne suis pas médecin
ce que je sais c'est que je suis pas
certain que ce soit du tout
véritablement le remède miracle mais ça
je dirais les tests et les études
médicales le diront oui ou non ce que je
constate c'est que beaucoup renoncent
avérée tellement à utiliser ce qui est
certain c'est qu'on ne peut pas faire de
l'auto médication bien sûr de ce côté là
il est évident qu'il va falloir être
prudent et ne pas se lancer dans la
démagogie et surtout non constate que
les querelles entre médecins valent les
querelles entre politiques
ça c'est vraiment extraordinaire et donc
il faut que ces querelles cesse et que
surtout je ne suis pas certain que la
visite du président de la république à
marseille est véritablement apporter
quelque chose de très positif parce que
sa relance peut-être des espoirs qui
sont malheureusement infondées merci
beaucoup jacques maire d'avoir répondu
en direct à nos questions et je rappelle
que vous êtes mère l'est républicain de
la ville de maisons-laffitte merci à
vous